we've got an update now on a six-month
cbs news investigation into a remote
military base
used by u.s service members after 9 11.
first on cbs this morning we've learned
that a bipartisan group of lawmakers
will introduce legislation in the house
and senate later today
now this would guarantee health coverage
and services for sick veterans who were
exposed to toxic materials
at the uzbekistan base known as k2
senior investigative correspondent
that's katherine herrich spoke with the
veterans who reported rare cancers
and other illnesses after being at that
base catherine good morning to you what
would this legislation mean
sounds like a very encouraging sign well
gail good morning if the k2 veterans
care act of 2021 becomes law it will be
an extraordinary victory
for these sick veterans and their
families after years of being denied
disability benefits
by the va k2 veteran mark jackson who
advocates on behalf of 15
000 service members who passed through
the former soviet air base
told cbs news the legislation would be a
home run
it does get me just a little emotional
just
tinge in the back of my throat a lump
because we work so hard for it and the
odds were stacked against it
and now we have bipartisan legislation
at the beginning of this congress
the legislation would establish what's
called a presumption of service
connection which means
sick k2 veterans will no longer have to
prove to the va that their illness is
linked
to toxic exposure at the base the image
in our reports of former air force
mechanic
doug wilson a brain cancer survivor
riding his electric wheelchair
along a busy florida highway to his
physical therapy appointments
struck a nerve with lawmakers this
legislation should get wilson more
financial help
better medical care and access to more
programs including transportation
to and from his appointments this
legislation
has tremendous momentum it has
bipartisan support
and the lawmakers sponsoring the bill
are hopeful they can get it done
in this session anthony that's great
news catherine that's what happens with
really solid reporting it can lead to
real
results thanks catherine herrich we
appreciate it